[Aplausos]
eu sou refugiado no brasil por ter ser
nascido mulher
eu não fugi de uma guerra do ar mas o
fugir de uma guerra do abusos
pra quem não sabe existe em vários
círculos dos refugiados de guerra
política perseguição étnica e vários
outros
eu tive que sair do meu país um marrocos
porque eu fui abusada psicologicamente
minha vida inteira porque eu sou mulher
eu cheguei ao ponto de querer morrer vou
votar no mundo homem no lugar da mulher
eu nasci numa família considerada
liberal nem o pai professor de filosofia
na casa branca
eu sou segunda de três irmãs meu pai
sempre deu pra mim muito amor mas ao
mesmo tempo sempre percebi que era que
essa culpa de não ter trazido o mundo o
menino no lugar de umas três meninas
mulher no marrocos significa viver com
medo medo dos era abusada pela sociedade
medo do ter cada dia menos autonomia
medo do querer ser libertados homem que
controla tudo na sua vida
medo de ter de as próprias diferente as
regras religiosas no marrocos sempre
tive que usar já aquela boca pra não
sofrer na rua sempre tinha que agüentar
será usada no trabalho porque eles me
consideram bonita no marrocos ulrich se
um decidir um dia me casar eu não
poderia me convocar porque a sociedade
nem e aceitar como divorciada
nem minha família e até aceitar
divorciada no marrocos e sinônimo de ser
prostituta mas sabe o estádio que ainda
pior ser grávida sem casamento
sem marido o ter sofrido do estupro
você vira um objeto do vergonha absoluta
para a família para a sociedade essa
cultura e não há cultura que eu quero
pros meus filhos eu quero uma cultura
que vai ser baseada no respeito mútuo é
que eles podem ser quem quiser eu não
sou contra a política religião cultura
meu país sou só contra as pessoas que
usa mão para agredir as mulheres
no meu país eu tinha uma amiga chamada
sara que foi grávida sem se casar e o
pai dela matou ela com várias facas
até aquela morreu por todos esses
motivos
eu fugi do meu país fez um ano e meio e
minhas dois irmãos também foram para
outros países
aqui no brasil eu entendi que eu posso
andar sozinha na rua que eu tinha que
ter vergonha de ser mulher que o poço
empreender que eu posso me vestir como
quiser
quando cheguei aqui no brasil eu tinha
algumas problemas na reintegração porque
tinha algumas pessoas que me perguntaram
cissé fazer bombas
o se meu marido me bati em casa mas fora
disso e sempre foi muito bem acolhida
até que tenho mais amigos brasileiros
que amigos árabe
aqui no brasil eu trabalhei muito
dia e noite até consegui realizar meu
sono e missoni uma região restaurante
aonde eu tô fazendo vários tipos da
comida oriente da síria do líbano
marrocos
basta significa sorriso eu escolhi esse
nome para dar boas energias sem muita
experiência para a minha vida aqui no
brasil também tem o conheci meu marido
na obras que é um círio eu me casei com
árabe mas que totalmente diferente
posso falar pra vocês que sem ele eu não
vou ser quem sou hoje há no brasil mas
conhecendo bem a situação das mulheres
árabe no marrocos no outro na todos os
outros países e 17 também aqui no brasil
as meninas estão passando pra se a são
ruins
algumas meninas que eu conheci que foi
abandonada pelo marido porque eles
ficaram grávidas têm problemas do
machismo tem a justiça então eu estou
perguntando como até agora no ciclo 21
as mulheres não conseguiram o respeito
que eles merecem
devemos só trocada planeta o deveremos ó
trocada a sociedade cada vez
por isso vamos trabalhar juntas para
conseguir o respeito que as mulheres
merecem
não obrigada obrigada obrigada prefeito
[Aplausos]